I could speak to my mental disorder I
would say I finally like what my body
looks like I would ask it to get off my
back if I could talk to my anxiety I
would say chill out
calm the [ __ ] down I'd say I finally
feel beautiful today it's not going to
run my life nice try
but I found marijuana and now you have
no chance at stopping me when I was 14 I
was diagnosed with anorexia I hated my
body I kept telling myself if I stopped
eating myself would thank me later on in
life I saw all these beautiful women who
didn't have their thighs touching and
they were very small
I have hips and I have curves and you
know I'm I'm a curvy woman and I never
felt accepted I never felt beautiful and
I never felt like my body was right I
started to like the feeling of my tummy
rumbling and the pain of not having
anything in my stomach it was probably
the most painful and like worst time of
my life I've had clinical depression
most of my life when I'm depressed I
don't feel bummed out all the time I
just sort of feel like laying down
because I don't want to do anything I
lose interest in the things that I used
to be passionate about I don't want to
hang out with my friends it makes it
hard to get out of bed in the morning it
makes it hard to exercise or cook a
decent meal a real life embodiment of my
anxiety could be like a black dog
constantly following me around this kind
of companion that whether I want it to
or not is always by my side it can be
really calm and may be comforting almost
sometimes but then like in the blink of
an eye I will just pounce on me
you know totally mess up whatever I'm
doing generalized anxiety is kind of
interesting in that I always have a
space level kind of panic going on I'm
freaking out like 95% of the time the
biggest thing I've learned about working
with my depression is just choosing
every day to live a like healthy vital
happy life constantly trying to resist
it isn't going to help as much as trying
to work with it I would say it's
important to know that your anxiety is
real and that you shouldn't let people
tell you to stop being a baby or to like
toughen up it's gonna get better
and it sounds so cheesy to some people
but when I look back at what I was like
when I was 14 and now I'm 24 over the
last ten years my view on my body has
completely changed I feel so beautiful
today I'm all about body positivity and
you never know how you're gonna grow in
your life if I could speak to my mental
disorder
I would say go away you're not welcome
anymore